madame la Présidente Monsieur le Premier
Ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers
collègues j'ai l'honneur d'être le
premier orateur après votre prise de
parole monsieur le Premier ministre et
votre intervention confirme la première
impression votre talent votre énergie
est un à tout dans la période que nous
[Applaudissements]
traversons et je pense que
nous sommes prêts à passer tous les caps
avec vous pas simplement le
caporne pour quelqu'un de ma
génération la nomination d'un jeune
premier ministre à quelque chose de
rassurant pour
l'avenir lorsque je me suis engagé en
1974 pendant la campagne de giscar vous
n'étiez pas né monsieur le Premier
ministre et bien d'autres avec Mariel de
SAR
notamment j'ai été
saisi même sentiment en 2017 avec le
président de la République et
aujourd'hui avec votre arrivée à
Matignon je ressens un peu ce même
mouvement cette même ardeur et j'ai
envie de dire
chich le discours que vous venez de
prononcer s'inscrit sur ce chemin du
dynamisme qui incarne l'esprit de 2017
les Français avaient alors choisi
l'optimisme l'ouverture et les valeurs
démocrates ce sont ces valeurs que
représenter et je vous sais conscient de
la responsabilité qui vous incombe
conscient de la hauteur de la tâche qui
est la vôtre et que vous abordez avec
l'audace et la détermination nécessaire
en étant précis et attentif aux attentes
concrètes des Français le groupe
démocrate que j'ai l'honneur de présider
vous fait confiance pour que vous soyez
fidèle à cette méthode fidèle à vos
valeurs pour mettre en œuvre une
politique volontariste et réformiste
vous avez été élu pour la première fois
en même temps que nombre d'entre nous
vous êtes en quelque sorte l'un d'entre
nous nous avons confiance en vous et en
la promesse que vous venez de faire de
travailler en étroite collaboration avec
le Parlement la transformation de notre
pays notre groupe vous accompagnera dès
lors que vous ne proposerai de
travailler main dans la main pour des
réformes utiles et justes à ce moment de
mon intervention permettez-moi d'envoyer
un signe d'amitié et de respect envers
ellisabeth borne qui a su conduire notre
majorité
depuis
[Musique]
2022 de façon utile et constructive je
veux ici la remercier pour tout ce
qu'elle a donné à notre
pays Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous
le savez vous y avvez participé beaucoup
de réformes ont été engagées depuis 2017
pour favoriser l'économie d'entreprise
et l'emploi nous avons lancé de grands
chantiers les lois et SOC Pact élan
etgalim mais il faut reconnaître que par
la la force des crises les gilets jaunes
la crise sanitaire la guerre en Ukraine
nous avons beaucoup paré à l'urgence
sans nous projeter avec vigueur dans
l'avenir force de constater également
que la France de 2024 n'est plus la
France de 2017 la guerre est désormais
sur notre sol les catastrophes
climatiques deviennent plus récurrentes
et brutales que jamais et l'accession
des pouvoirs des populistes au pouvoirs
des populistes dans nos nombreux pays du
monde renversent les anciens équilibres
le monde le moment est venu de rebondir
d'être à l'offensive et vous venez de le
prouver au groupe démocrate nous
demandons des grandes lois structurantes
sur le long terme avec de la
programmation et la sécurité juridique
telles les lois de programmation de la
défense la justice ou la police sur des
marqueurs sociétaux sur lesquels nous
pourrions retrouver l'adhésion de nos
concitoyens dans cette nouvelle méthode
le groupe démocrate vous accompagnera
avec ce que nous sommes déterminé à
redonner de la force à notre pays lui
rendre sa souveraineté rendre les
Français fiers de constituer une nation
unie et solidaire nous avons de nombreux
défis à surmonter et je veux avant tout
vous apportez ainsi qu'à votre Ministre
de l'Agriculture Marc fenau notre plein
soutien pour résoudre la crise agricole
actuelle cette crise est multiforme et
le reste des sujets que nous avons à
traiter les tout autant comment
réindustrialiser le pays pour créer des
emplois et assurer notre souveraineté
comment accueillir les travailleurs dans
un territoire quand on n pas de logement
pour les accueillir avec leurs familles
comment répondre à l'exigence de
simplification sans verser dans le tout
numérique la mauvaise calibration du
guichet unique montre qu'il nous faut
faire confiance aux tiers que nous avons
besoin de maintenir le contact et le
succès des maisons de Fran serv est à
cet égard très parlant comment demander
au français d'assurer le renouvellement
des générations quand il est impossible
de trouver une pièce en plus pour loger
des enfants à naître comment redonner
confiance quand la solidarité
l'ascenseur social l'école sont en perte
de vitesse quand la culture est réservée
à certains seulement comment prendre en
charge nos aînés soigner les Français
tous quel que soit le territoire dans
lequel il résident voilà les défis qui
sont devant nous et notre devoir est de
répondre à l'ensemble de ces questions
en les menant de franc ensemble en
tenant compte des deux éléments
fondamentaux la crise environnementale
qui doit guider l'ensemble de nos
politiques et la crise préoccupante de
nos finances publiques vous avez
beaucoup insister monsieur le Premier
ministre sur le travail qui celui qui
rémunère celui qui fait vivre une
famille vous parlez du travail qui
émancipe et là-dessus nous sommes avec
vous faciliter les formations les
embauches pour les entreprises leur
simplifier pour qu'ils passent plus de
temps à chercher de nouveaux marchés ou
déposer des brevets plutôt qu'à faire de
la paperasse nous devons également nous
interroger sur notre fiscalité qui n'est
plus adaptée au monde actuel agissons
contre les inégalités qu'elles soient
sociales économique ou environnemental
sans pour autant briser les talents vous
savez aussi Monsieur le Premier Ministre
notre grande préoccupation face à la
crise du logement et de l'immobilier
pour nous groupe démocrate le logement
est l'un des fils rouges de l'égalité
des chances de la naissance au derniers
jour le logement plutôt que de
représenter la première des inégalités
doit être un lieu d'émancipation alors
oui il faut absolument bâtir une
politique du logement cohérente humaine
et adapter à la société d'aujourd'hui
les solutions existent même si elle
passe par quelques bouverersements y
compris fiscaux certains États du monde
ont compris que pour réussir il fallait
gouverner à 30 ou 40 ans à en France
nous avons parfois pris l'habitude de
gouverner à 30 ou 40 jours cela ne peut
plus fonctionner notutre horison doit
être celui de la génération il en est de
même dans d'autres domaines tels que la
démographie année après année nous
voyons les naissances se tasser sans
réagir aujourd'hui nous avons un
indicateur de fécondité au plus bas
depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale hormis
en 93 et 94 cette question démographique
ne doit pas être prise à la légère elle
est cruciale cruciale pour l'avenir de
notre nation notre contrat social qui
fait la richesse de la France repose sur
cet indicateur il font nos politiques de
santé d'éducation nos politiques de
solidarité AG pour la progression
démographique suppose d'abord et avant
tout de combattre une totale
détermination avec une totale
détermination les inégalités éradiquer
les inégalités de destin celles qui font
que lorsqu'on est dans un certain
quartier dans un certain milieu social
sur sous certain nom de famille on y est
condamné à vie il faut une politique
familiale et une protection de l'enfance
ambitieuse comme ce que nous avons bâti
depuis 6 ans la création d'une
délégation au droit de l'enfant au sein
de notre assemblée est en est une belle
illustration l'éducation ensuite qui est
le cœur même de l'émancipation de tous
les élèves tous les élèves doivent se
prévaloir des mêmes chance dans toutes
les écoles meilleur suivi des élèves des
classes à taille humaine le métier de
professeur revalorisé tels sont les
chantiers sur lesquels nous avons
commencé à travailler ces dernières
années et que nous devons poursuivre
avec davantage de vigueur nous savons
tous ici que la réussite du système
éducatif dépend surtout du bien-être de
l'accompagnement et du nombre de
professions
encourageant les vocation mettant en
œuvre une vraie politique de formation
aidant les à s'installer dans tous les
territoires au-delà un autre défi et non
des moines nous attend celui du
vieillissement massif de la population
qui entraîne des défis immenses
explosion des dépenses de protection
sociale besoin d'aménagement de la vie
quotidienne notamment en matière de
logement nouvelles exigences des
services publics en termees d'assistance
et de soins je souhaiterais aussi
aborder vous l'avez un petit peu fait
monsieur Premier ministre les défis des
territoire je parle de tous les
territoires d'exagone bien évidemment
mais également tous nos territoires
d'outrem qui méritent une attention
forte du gouvernement maintenir notre
modèle économique et social suppose de
mener une politique volontariste de
réduction des des inégalités territorial
l'une des fractures les plus fortes
réside dans l'accès aux soins sur les
déserts médicaux le comp pas malgré tous
nos efforts soutenant les médecins
volontaires pour aller dans des zones
oubliées l'ouverture du numérosclosus
est actée mais reste insuff
l'exigence d'égalité territoriale c'est
aussi l'accès au services publics avec
une administration qui aide plutôt que
de traquer et punir et c'est enfin en
soutient à notre agriculteur à nos
agriculteurs comment accepter qu'après
les lois égalim nous en soyons toujours
même constat nos agriculteurs qui
nourrissent par leur force de travail
les Français n'arrivent toujours pas à
vivre décemment leur activité il reste
coincé dans le faossé de la grande que
la grande distribution a largement
creuser entre le consommateur et le
producteur vous venez encore de faire
encore à l'instant de faire de fortes
propositions qui viendront s'ajouter au
grand texte à venir sur le
renouvellement des générations je
souhaite qu'ell soit de nature à
répondre enfin à ce mal-être agricole
profond mais là encore toujours avec une
vision à long terme voici Monsieur le
Premier Ministre ce que nous croyons et
ce que nous espérons pouvoir faire avec
vous dans un contexte de grand
bouleversement le plus grand
boueverersement nous l'avons tous en
tête
le dérèglement climatique avec la
question du pouvoir d'achat les
fractures territoriales l'inflation il
est de plus en plus difficile de faire
accepter à nos concitoyens des
changements dans leur mode de
consommation alors que ce renforce
l'impérieuse nécessité d'agir et et fort
pour et fort d'agir vite et fort pardon
pour produire nos émissions pour réduire
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre la
question la plus délicate est donc de
savoir qui finance la transition
énergétique et comment faire en sorte
que les Français ne subissent pas ne
subissent pas cette transition c'est un
enjeu important Monsieur le Premier
Ministre auquel vous allez devoir vous
atteler car si nous sommes tous
convaincus que l'urgence est là nous
devons pas assister impuissant à la
dégradation du vivant notre partenaire
le plus important sur ce sujet comme sur
l'agriculture la défense la solidarité
la santé sera une nouvelle fois l'Union
européenne 2024 sera l'année européenne
et j'ai confiance dans tous les
démocrates pour mettre toutes leurs
forces dans la campagne des valeurs
européennes la liberté l'État de droit
l'égalité la solidarité et c'est encore
plus important face au grand
bouleversement à l'échelle
internationale dont je le crains nous
n'avons pas encore véritablement pris la
pleine mesure ce sont bien évidemment
les conséquences de la situation
Moyen-Orient la détresse et les
souffrances du peuple ukrainien ou
encore les incertitudes liées aux
élections
américaines ce qui se joue est donc de
de renforcer de consolider l'Union
européenne les Européens doivent
défendre leurs valeurs et leur mode de
vie ils ne pourront le faire que s'ils
s'unissent face aux grands risques
mondiaux nous avons d'autres nous
n'avons d'autre choix que de nous
préparer nous Européens défendre nos
valeurs européennes et démocrates cela
implique aussi de changer de méthode
dans notre hémicycle monsieur le Premier
ministre je le disais au début de mon
propos votre nomination nous l'esprit de
2017 et renoué avec 2017 c'est aussi
renoué avec le dépassement dépassement
d'clivage des antagonismes des postures
dépassement au fond de nos vieilles
habitudes le groupe démocrate défend
depuis longtemps l'importance de moins
légiférer pour mieux légiférer en
travaillant sur moins de textes mais des
textes plus
structurants mieux évaluer aussi
l'efficacité des politiques publiques je
sais bien sûr que nos difficultés sont
aussi liées à notre mode de scrutin
premier germe de la division ainsi nous
devons nous poser cette question pour
raviver notre démocratie tout cela
implique de faire des efforts de
davantage respecter nos différences
plutôt que de les cultiver ce sont les
qualités qui prévalent au groupes
démocrate et qui s'est construit sur
l'unité la positivité l'écoute la
liberté le dépassement de conflits par
le rassemblement des valeurs c'est dans
l'ADN du groupe du mouvement démocrate
d'avoir une vision sociale démocrate et
humaniste et nous serons à vos côtés
Monsieur le Premier Ministre pour la
faire vivre je vous
remercie je vous remercie monsieur le
président